[Music]
welcome to the worlds of
new pokemon snap this is the lentil
region
you'll ride the neo one through the
jungle
across the desert and even under the sea
to research pokemon in their natural
habitats
and of course you won't be alone
professor mirror who's doing research in
the lentil region
and research team members rita and phil
are there to support you
so you're in good hands
now then let's get that research started
by watching wild pokemon you can
discover behaviors and expressions
that are rarely seen look a surfing
alolan raichu
and there's vaporeon let's try throwing
in a fluff fruit
that's it now's our chance
[Music]
oh it's tyranitar
what a wild way to eat
here's a park at night let's try playing
a melody
oh that sure made hut happy
you'll also have illumina orbs something
the professor invented
if you use one of these you can make any
pokemon glow
[Music]
whoa those flames changed color
[Music]
make good use of your tools to take
shots that really stand out
then show the photos you took to the
professor
oh four stars we captured a rare moment
there
catch a variety of different behaviors
on camera
to fill up your pokemon photo decks and
there's more
you'll be able to edit the photos you've
taken
use features like stickers and frames to
make your favorite photos
even more special and i'm sure you'll
want to show off your best photos right
we know that feeling well when you want
to do that
it's time to go online you can share
your favorite photos
and check out photos from around the
world and if your photo becomes popular
it might even be featured and get more
attention
seeing something like that may inspire
you to go back and take
even more photos we're getting closer to
the start of your adventure
unexplored islands and plenty of pokemon
await in the lentil region
so make sure you're prepared
[Music]
whoa is that the mythical pokemon celebi
get ready the lentil region is waiting
for you